let's go to our five headlines
[Music]
another night of the dnc last night god
help us
i didn't watch it again because i don't
hate myself well i do hate myself but
not enough to expose myself to such
tortures intentionally
the highlight of the night though had to
be accused rapist bill clinton giving
his speech which was so
laid in with irony that you know it may
cause an overdose
so here's bill for example giving a
lecture
on how to behave in the oval office
donald trump says we're leading the
world
well we are the only major industrial
economy to have its unemployment rate
tripled
at a time like this the oval office
should be a command center
instead it's a storm center there's only
chaos
just one thing never changes his
determination to deny responsibility
and shift the blame the buck never stops
there
now you have to decide whether to renew
his contract or hire someone else
if you want a president who defines the
job as spending hours a day watching tv
and zapping people on social media he's
your man
they really might as well have michael
moore come give a lecture on nutrition
and fitness
i mean they might as well have elizabeth
warren speak at the native american
caucus meeting
oh wait no they they they actually did
that too um
yeah they're yes they're they are trying
to give us an irony overdose i think
that's that's the dastardly plot here
now as for slick willie uh we should
remember that clinton didn't just take
advantage of a young
intern while he was president and lie
about it uh and perjure himself he
and he wasn't just accused of sexual
harassment multiple times by multiple
women he was also accused of rape
violent forcible rape credibly accused
a lot of even the critical coverage of
bill's dnc speech
makes no mention of the rape accusation
for example
a piece in the daily beast eloquently
titled why the f
is creepy bill clinton speaking at the
democratic convention
doesn't so they cut right to the chase
with the title i i like that but it
doesn't make any reference to the rape
charge
it excoriates the dnc for having bill
clinton because he's a dinosaur he
represents the past he's antiquated and
so on
um and uh and yes he was inappropriate
with some women but but even the critics
of clinton
can't on the left anyway can't bring
themselves to admit
that he was credibly accused of pushing
a woman down on a hotel bed
and forcibly violating her the other
thing
not mentioned is bill's many many trips
to and fro
with global pedophile and sex trafficker
jeffrey epstein speaking of which new
photos emerged yesterday you can take a
look at that
there's creepy bill as we're calling him
now keeping getting a massage
from one of epstein's sex trafficking
victims
and unless you are naive to the point of
being essentially catatonic
you should know that there is nothing
innocent about going on a trip with your
pedophile buddy
and getting a massage from one of his
sex slaves in fact we have heard
from epstein's victims that these
massages were part of the grooming
ritual
so this is certainly nothing innocent
here and this is big news what you're
seeing right here
a former president being massaged by a
sex-trafficked
girl in the company of an international
pedophile
but you wouldn't know it from the media
coverage which is uh
which has been almost non-existent
number two
it's like groundhog day at this point
reporting this every day but i'm not
going to ignore it blm
rioters in portland again last night
as we go into our what is it third month
of this and they attacked a police
station set it on fire
here's the footage of
here hold this that yep
we've really reached a point where
left-wing demonstrators setting a police
station on fire
is like par for the course oh they set
another police station on fire
well what are you gonna do there was a
time
when this would have been treated as a
very big deal
and it is a big deal and should still be
treated as such
and this is why speaking of
conservatives being ineffective
uh the argument that you hear from a lot
of conservatives is that
well we shouldn't really do anything and
trump shouldn't do anything
uh because we you know th this these are
leftist cities
and just let them destroy themselves and
you know that's how we stick it to the
left is by letting them destroy
themselves
uh i think there are a lot of problems
with that mentality
starting with the fact that not
everybody in
one of these cities is there are just
normal decent people living in these
cities that are being victimized here
they're not all a bunch of crates yeah
if it was a city entirely comprised of
violent lunatic left-wing activists then
i would say yeah just let them you know
it's it's lord of the flies and just
let them do what they're gonna do but uh
or maybe i would say that actually
i probably even then wouldn't but it's
certainly not in this case because there
are actual
victims in these cases and then the
second point is
um even aside from that
we are letting the criminals do what
they want i don't understand how that's
supposed to be some sort of punishment
i don't know how that's supposed to be
us winning by
letting them do letting them commit
crimes letting them
with impunity do whatever they want no
that is letting the criminals win we are
we are
letting them win by letting them do what
they want
and i don't think we should it only
emboldens them
and it only guarantees more of this in
the future i think it's a terrible
strategy it's not really a strategy
at all it's a non-strategy it's just
it's just doing nothing
number three reading from the daily wire
says massachusetts officials are
reportedly calling the police and the
state's department of children and
families
on parents whose children fail to show
up for their school district's
zoom school those are the the classes
that are live streamed
the boston globe reports that
massachusetts school officials have
reported dozens of families to state
social workers for possible neglect
because of issues related to their
children's participation in remote
learning
classes during the pandemic shutdown in
the spring in most cases the outlet
notes the referrals were made solely
because the students failed to log into
class repeatedly
most of the parents reported were
mothers and several did not have any
previous involvement with social
services so now they have that on their
record um
and of course you can you can totally
see why a parent wouldn't bother having
their kid
log into the zoom class because you know
i
if if if we're doing this i can just
teach them myself right there's no
reason to i'm not gonna have my kid
sit in a computer sit in front of a
computer all day to learn this is not
the right way i'll just do it myself
i think a lot of parents were saying
that and now they get visits from social
services
and this of course goes back to what we
discussed last week that the school
system
thinks it owns your child that your
children belong to it
so even when they shut down
and don't let your child come to school
they still want to keep tabs
they still are owed in their minds your
child's attention and allegiance and
obedience
and they will literally try to throw you
in jail if you don't comply
i really think a day will come when
people look back on this kind of thing
look back on the modern public school
system
in general and just shake their heads in
horror and disbelief
thinking like how did parents ever
subject their children to that
intentionally that's what they'll ask
and it'll be a good question and the
thing is
i don't have a good answer even now
though i'm living through it
number four fox news reports important
story here
um very important it says a bride
recently posted online about how her
mother gave a vicious speech at her
wedding last year which
led the groomsmen to ask her mother to
leave the reception in the post on
reddit's am i the a-hole forum
uh the pro the bride a user of the forum
explained that she didn't really feel
comfortable
allowing her mom to speak at a wedding
because of their strained relationship
she says quote i ultimately let her
hoping she would deliver the same fluff
about gaining a son that she did at my
sister's wedding
according to the red post the mom
insulted the bride's appearance her
quote crappy apartment and her gross
medical issues this is during the the
speech at the reception
she said each time she paused to let a
joke land there was silence
my husband and wedding party stared at
me frozen waiting for my cue on how to
react
they stayed seated in until her bit
about how i am damaged goods referring
to a time when i was 19.
i had a bad date and the guy harassed me
for over a year it seriously impacted my
mental health and i dropped out of
college it's painful to think or talk
about
then it goes on to say that the mom was
asked to leave the wedding and she's
very offended by that now there's a
strained relationship with the daughter
even more strained as you can imagine
all right just just just two quick
points here
um the reason i bring this up this story
and first of all the first one is i have
been to
plenty of weddings and i have never
witnessed a moment like this and so i'm
pretty jealous i've never seen anything
this entertaining
also this is an opportunity for me
really to go over what i believe the
rules should be
for wedding receptions um because the
way we go about wedding receptions is
all wrong
wedding receptions are exhausting and
excruciating
for for everybody involved uh they're
really not a lot of fun
and it doesn't have to be this way now
this one sounds like it was pretty
entertaining but usually they aren't
uh but but but they would be if
everybody followed my rules so let me
tell you what the rules are and of
course when i am
when i when i take over and my reign
begins as theocratic dictator these
rules will be
uh will be codified into law and
punishable by death
or a 50 fine or both number one
if you aren't going to have booze at
your wedding you should be legally
barred from getting married
dry wedding receptions are a violation
of the eighth
eighth amendment's ban on cruel and
unusual punishment
i almost said they're a violation of the
ten commandments of which they which i
would say they even are that too somehow
especially a dry wedding where i don't
know if you've ever been to one of these
a dry wedding no alcohol
but they still have music and dancing
now if you're gonna go puritan
then go full puritan have no alcohol no
dancing
we'll get in and out in 15 minutes and
if we're doing that then okay fine
i'll allow that but you want to have a
four and a half hour reception
with music and dancing but no alcohol
like
you think you're gonna get us onto the
floor for the cha-cha slide and we have
had no beer ahead of time
not gonna happen number two um wedding
reception food
is usually a letdown there are some
exceptions to this i went to my friend's
wedding last year
uh he's indian so he had indian food
like curry and stuff like that was very
very good
so that you know there are some
exceptions but usually the food is bad
so uh just what i would say no food
people pack a lunch a ham sandwich
really it's about the booze anyway third
thing finally more to the point of this
story
all speeches should be banned at wedding
receptions giving an effective speech is
actually a highly difficult skill to
master and 99.9
of people in the world do not have the
skill that's why most speeches you hear
at weddings at fundraising banquets and
other types of events
are horrendous because they're be they
aren't being delivered by trained
professionals they're being delivered by
amateurs who have no idea what they're
doing
so uh that's what i would say either
have no speeches at all
how egotistical is it anyway to carve
out time
in your wedding reception for people to
get up and say nice things about you
so you're planning it you're saying okay
so at this point here in the schedule
we'll have 47 people
take turns uh saying nice things about
us into a microphone
yeah that's a good idea absolute
narcissism
uh so no speeches or you can hire a
trained professional
to give one speech just one and on that
note i am available
a rate of 95 dollars a word not a bad
considering how much you spend at
weddings really that's
that's a pretty good bargain all right
number so those are those are the rules
uh
five finally we have one more
headline these aren't really headlines
but uh but just go with it lena dunham
of course one of the great minds and
great talents of our time has given us
another offering
another thing to think about and i just
want to play that for you here it is
[Music]
yeah i'm sorry i just i saw that
i felt like i had to deal with it
psychologically because i was exposed to
it and so
then i exposed you to it also really
misery loves company i had to do it
and i just why
why maybe this isn't the lead here i
don't know but why is she wearing a
bathing suit
that says sex on it like
that's about the that when it comes to
being a provocateur that's about on the
level of when you're in middle school
and you type numbers into your
calculator and turn it upside down so it
says
boobs you know it's like on that level
this is someone who who wants to be
provocative but has run out of tricks
there are no more tricks in her bag she
reached into her bag came up empty
and said oh i know i'll i'll wear a
bathing suit that says sex on it
super edgy stuff so there's lena dunham
that's what she's up to if you're
wondering
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content